history has been
the pursuit of a false god
the god of stability the god of
permanence
the god of the unchanging and we've
become
just neurotic on this subject people
were just fed up with the 20th century
by night by the time the atom bomb
arrived and what they wanted and what
they had been promised by the new deal
democrats was a paradise
well the only way you could deliver
paradise in that political con
text was it had to be an air airsats
paradise
a paradise of stucco and tv
and tv dinners and tube furniture
and that's what they got
they got an airsats paradise and then
out of that come the discontent of their
children
who see that howdy doody and a water
sprinkler on the front lawn
doesn't feel like paradise you know
and and that has what has driven
american society uh deeper
and deeper into artificiality is the
need to supply
this synthetic manufactured paradise
that's why the cult of the celebrity
and the intense media saturation
and all of this is diversion
diverticement the substitute for a life
that's why what
get a life means is
go get stoned go get laid
go climb a mountain or kayak a river
but somehow take back your own
authenticity
from the people who are peddling you
canned experience with
laugh tracks with caffeine
augmentation and so forth and so on and
the real message of psychedelics i think
is to reclaim
experience and to trust yourself
your perceptions are primary your
feelings
are correct everything must constellate
out and make sense and parse
with what you know if you don't start
from that
assumption then you are off center to
begin with
and the psychedelics will dissolve the
cultural programming that has
potentially made you a mark and restore
your authenticity and
you know that's what it's all about
whether the only transformation in life
is the personal dying that awaits each
of us
or whether there is a grand opening and
opportunity just ahead at the end of
history
that's awesome
the bottom line of this from
a feeling and a heart place
is that what's being said here is
reclaim experience
do not dwell in the mistakes of the past
do not lose yourself in the castles of
the future
and do not give your authenticity away
to experts gurus
government commissions
bosses wives mates
[Music]
take back your mind and your body
and begin to
engage with the fact that you are alive
you are going to die nobody knows what
being alive
is nobody knows what dying is
you're involved in a a mysterious
engagement where every living moment
presents you with mystery opportunity
and wonder
there is no mundane uh
dimension really if you have the eyes to
see it
it's it's all transcendental
and every every uh
object a leaf a bird a pebble everything
leads back to the basic questions
everything is the stone i mean the stone
is present
it's a matter of you being present for
the stone
[Music]
you